les agences régionales de santé
aujourd'hui c'est du jacobinisme
régional finalement puisqu'elle ne font
que ce que fait le ministère de la santé
dans son ministère
c'est à dire produire de la norme nous
nous pensions d'une part les agences
régionales de santé devrait être
beaucoup plus nous pas diriger mais
beaucoup plus en lien avec les élus
que ce soit les présidents de régions où
les présidents de département ou par le
biais par exemple d'une conférence
départementale de santé ou les élus
locaux seraient beaucoup plus impliqué
bien ça ça serait beaucoup plus c'est
pas avoir du pouvoir prend du pouvoir
mais ensemble on est beaucoup plus
intelligent et quand on a plusieurs
prisme évidemment on augmente le degré
d' analyse et puis d'autre part ce que
nous pensions nous c'est que ça n'était
pas au ministère de la santé en fait de
faire les choses parce que ces crises
avant d'être une crise sanitaire on l'a
bien vu elle était une crise de la
logistique pour les tests pour les
masques pour l'organisation des ehpad
pour l'organisation des écoles et si on
poursuit le raisonnement on se rend
compte que le ministère de la santé
était probablement le moins armé pour
être le ministère de la logistique et le
ministère la logistique c'était
évidemment le ministère de l'intérieur
donc tout ça ce sont des analyses que
nous avons faites alors l on ne l'a pas
fait parce qu'on s'est réuni dans un
bureau à cinq dont les quatre était le
clone les clones du premier nous l'avons
pas parce que nous avons écouté les
maires nous avons écouté les
associations départementales
nous avons eu de ce qu'on appelle des
remontées terrain et évidemment c'est ça
qui nous a permis de faire ces
propositions là et ce qui est dommage
c'est que cette ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui ce pauvre feu alors le terme
en plus c'est évidemment très très conne
haute et est très violent par pur pour
pour être accepté enfin le degré
d'acceptabilité il passe aussi par le
mot que l'on choisit et le couvre-feu
évidemment serment qui est très très
fort et bien tout ce qu on en subit
aujourd'hui ce qu'on est obligé
d'accepter ce qu'on accepte elysées lui
font en sorte que ça se passe le mieux
possible
peut-être aurait pu être modulée par la
qualité de l'échéance pour n'aurait dû
avoir juste après
après après le printemps
[Musique]